Part 1 of Masters of the Universe: Revelation
ends on a huge cliffhanger with the fate of
He-Man and Skeletor revealed, and hidden in
the first five episodes are a stack of clues
you might have missed which also predict what
could happen next.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing all the crucial details
from the new Netflix He-Man series plus theories
for Part 2!
Many thanks to World of Tanks for sponsoring
this video.
Obviously, spoilers ahead, so take care.
The ending of Part 1 sees Adam, Teela and
her band of heroes return to Eternia with
the Sword of Power reforged thanks to Roboto's
heroic sacrifice.
The sword had been split in two when He-Man
used it to absorb the exploding Orb of Power
that Skeletor cracked open at the beginning
of the series.
The energy from the orb not only killed Adam,
but also nearly all the magic that held Eternia
together vanished when each half of the Sword
of Power disappeared to Preternia and Subternia,
aka Heaven and Hell.
So when Adam holds the restored sword aloft
and says "By the power of Grayskull", he's
able to call back the Power and reinstate
magic in Eternia.
The Hall of Wisdom becomes Castle Grayskull
again and the Orb of Power is restored and
locked away.
However, just as Adam is about to complete
the phrase and transform into He-Man, Skeletor
makes a surprise return and stabs Adam through
his midriff with his Havoc Staff.
Skeletor, like He-Man, vanished when the Orb
of Power exploded in the first episode, and
he reveals that to avoid being completely
destroyed by the blast, he hid his essence
in Evil-Lyn's wand staff.
Skeletor's trick was hinted at a number of
times in earlier episodes such as when Evil-Lyn's
orb lit up mysteriously and when it began
whispering at one point.
[otherworldly whispers]
And Teela funnily enough was unwittingly closer
to the truth than she realised when she made
a jibe at Evil-Lyn in the third episode:
Take no life advice from the likes of Evil-Lyn,
Andra.
Remember, she's the only one here carrying
around a Skeletor in her closet.
So, after Skeletor's shocking defeat of He-Man
– which must be the first time in the animated
franchise's history – the villain takes
the Sword of Power for himself, and says the
magic words which transform him into a god
version of himself, Skelegod.
Now I...
Skeletor...
am Master of the Universe!
Now, let's talk about that possibly lethal
stabbing that Skeletor landed on Adam.
Notice the location of the wound which is
roughly around the same place
- in the middle of the body –
where Adam stabbed Skeletor in the first episode
and we know that he managed to survive that.
You finally used that sword the way it was
meant to be used.
By the way, Skeletor's line there is a nod
to how in the Filmation animated series, He-Man
never used his sword in a violent way against
his opponents and, as a kids' show, the series
as a whole also shied away from serious violence.
Masters of the Universe: Revelation is a continuation
of the 80s series, however, it's clearly a
lot darker with real fights taking place between
the characters with some of them even trying
to kill each other.
And given this darker path for the new series,
I think that initially in Part 2 Adam could
well be confirmed dead.
This would hit particularly hard as he was
told before he left Preternia that his next
death would probably not allow him back into
Heaven.
If you were to return to Eternia...
You might never be able to come back here.
You would end as mortals do:
in dirt.
However, there is precedence for He-Man dying
in the franchise, specifically the He-Man/Thundercats
comic book crossover where Adam also died
and came back to life.
After being brutally stabbed with the Sword
of Power in the books, Adam was initially
able to heal his mortal wounds by holding
onto the sword while saying his classic catchphrase.
Later, however, Adam died but was resurrected
after being entombed with the Sword of Power.
In the Netflix show, we might see something
similar in Part 2, with Teela and the other
heroes banding together again, this time to
find a way to take the Sword of Power from
Skeletor and revive Adam.
Evil-Lyn might also be a key part of that,
which I'll talk more about shortly.
Orko is another major character who appeared
to die, but I suspect he might not have.
In the Land of the Dead episode, Orko confronted
his fears that he'd never be able to control
his magical abilities.
As he and the team tried to leave Subternia,
Scare Glow arrived to attack them one final
time.
In a display of magical mastery, Orko froze
the falling rocks that were about to land
on Teela and the others, then bravely fended
off Scare Glow, giving them an opportunity
to escape.
Look!
I'm doing it!
I'm not afraid.
He can't scare me.
Orko then trapped Scare Glow with his magic
rings and tried to blast him away.
Demon be gone...
Go back to your shadow!!
The resulting explosion saw Orko and Scare
Glow vanish, while throwing Teela and co through
the portal to Preternia, with just a fragment
of Orko's cloak floating through the door
as it closed.
When Adam discovered what happened, he built
a memorial stone to honour his fallen friend,
assuming that he'd died;
however, I don't think that's the case.
In fact, Orko's battle with Scare Glow in
the underworld may have actually turned the
his character into a much darker version for
Part 2.
And just before I reveal the truth about Dark
Orko, I want to thank this video's sponsor
"World of Tanks".
World of Tanks is an epic online team game
with over 100 million players worldwide.
And it's free-to-play in glorious HD on your
PC.
The game's just launched a huge G.I.
Joe crossover event with G.I.
Joe Breakthrough and Cobra Battle Operational
Assault Tank Styles that runs until July 30th.
With our special invite code, you'll get free
G.I.
Joe and Cobra emblems to customize your tanks.
And if you complete one of the event's special-themed
missions, you'll get extra rewards to fully
kit out your tank with bonus decals and inscriptions.
World of Tanks is full of authentic historical
detail and with over 550 tanks available,
you'll feel like a real commander.
Plan a campaign with teammates and defeat
your enemies in over 40 battle arenas.
Download the game for free right now and during
the registration use the invite code GIJOE21
to activate in-game missions and receive free
GI Joe emblems to decorate your tanks.
The code also gets you a T14 tank (Tier 5),
500,000 credits, and 7 days of a premium account
completely free.
The download link and invite code are in the
video description.
To understand why we may be getting Dark Orko
in Part 2, we need to look at what happened
to Orko in the DC Universe vs The Masters
of the Universe comics.
In that comic book storyline, Orko ended up
absorbing an evil force when he tried to destroy
the Skull of Power, and that unlocked the
mental barriers that had been holding him
back, transforming him into Dark Orko.
That's an interesting parallel with what happens
to Orko in the Land of the Dead where he explained
how he struggled with magic when he was young,
but then we see him master it in his showdown
with Scare Glow.
During that crucial battle, Orko summoned
an immense amount of magic and tried to banish
the villain, similar to how he tried to destroy
the Skull of Power in the comics.
That attempt to defeat Scare Glow, who was
holding onto Orko during the explosion which
followed, may have transformed the Trollan
into something else, for example if he absorbed
some of the evil being's megalomaniac traits
and wicked powers.
The gold rings that Orko conjured during his
encounter with Scare Glow are similar to the
fiery rings of magic that Dark Orko uses in
the comic.
And the shadow beasts that attack Orko and
Evil-Lyn in Subternia are a little reminiscent
of the horde that Dark Orko unleashes in the
books.
We might find that, in Part 2 of Revelation,
Dark Orko has replaced Scare Glow as the ruler
of the underworld, commanding an army of shadow
monsters himself now.
I think introducing Dark Orko could add another
intriguing element to the show as it would
be quite unexpected and in keeping with the
darker themes and tone of the new series.
My other big prediction for Part 2 and beyond
is that although Evil-Lyn switched back to
Skeletor's side, she may end up betraying
him and even helping the good guys again in
the future.
I really was starting to like you kids.
Perhaps Evil-Lyn thought it was best to feign
she was still loyal to her villainous boss
in that moment, with a view to potentially
usurping him at a later point.
After all, she regretted some of the time
she'd spent working for him.
Instead of fulfilling my destiny, I spent
a lifetime helping him fulfill his.
In the 80s animated series, Evil-Lyn sometimes
carried out her own schemes independent of
Skeletor.
In fact, in the episode "The Witch and the
Warrior", when Lyn found herself having to
work with Teela, she revealed that what she
was really after was her own power.
I have no loyalty to Skeletor, it is power
I want.
Someday, I'll seize it from him.
I very much expect that at some point in Revelation,
Evil-Lyn will end up being full-on resentful
of being Skeletor's sidekick.
On top of that, I think she may have grown
genuinely fond of Teela and the gang, and
we saw a glimpse of that when she opened up
to Orko during their time together in the
underworld.
No, they didn't call me "Evil,"
I added that part later.
[chuckles]
Lyn also used the last of her magic to conjure
the doorway that would take them all from
Subternia to Preternia, which Orko said proved
that she might not be so bad deep down.
Turns out nobody's born evil.
If Skeletor doesn't give Lyn any real opportunities
for power in Part 2, which I don't expect
he will now he's Skelegod, I think she may
well end up turning against him and even helping
Teela out as well.
We also need to talk about Teela, as there
are many hints to a secret side of her that
hasn't yet been fully revealed.
In fact, there were several moments in Part
1 where somebody was about to reveal a big
secret about her but they got cut off:
There's something I have to tell you...
Oh, no.
We don't have time.
Because you have a special--
Don't you understand?
Teela.
There's... there's something--
[Teela] Don't.
I don't want to hear it.
The secret that everyone seems to want to
tell Teela is that
- spoiler alert -
her mother is the Sorceress of Castle Grayskull.
This was something revealed to Teela in the
second episode of the Filmation series.
You are my own daughter and someday you will
take my place as the mystic guardian of Grayskull.
At the time, however, the Sorceress decided
to wipe Teela's memory of this knowledge.
For now you have other deeds to do.
You must forget what you have learned today.
And this secret is why the Sorceress calls
Teela to Castle Grayskull when she fears she
may die during Skeletor's attack.
I wanted to see you, Teela, one last time.
Me?
We see how Teela has been avoiding dealing
with a sense that's she's different when the
evil version of herself confronts her in Subternia.
Pretending to be ordinary when you know, deep
down, you are so much more.
And how that must terrify you...
Teela admits to Scare Glow that she's never
understood her power, but then proves her
connection to her magical heritage as she
manifests the missing piece of the Sword of
Power by herself.
What...
are you?
Notice these three marks that appear on Teela's
forehead momentarily as she creates the sword
as I think we'll see those again in the future.
As the original Filmation series suggests,
Teela may take over from her mother the Sorceress
as the Guardian of Grayskull, should she ever
die or need to step down.
And although Teela was able to call on her
power that one time in the underworld, she
will need to fully embrace her magical side
if she wants to take over that role.
So, what did you think of MOTU: Revelation
and do you have any theories on what could
happen next?
And did you spot any other details or easter
eggs?
Let me know in the comments below!
If you enjoyed this, then leave a thumbs-up
and subscribe for more videos like this.
You can tap left to check out my next video
or tap right for something else you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!